la nation du feu devient de plus en plus
menaçante et le monde pourrait bien ne
pas s'en
relever le monde a besoin de
l'avatar le monde a besoin de toi
[Musique]
hang la Nation du Feu a tout détruit sur
T
passage pour que le monde ait une chance
de survivre il va avoir besoin de Hang
ouais je vois il est doué ton sauveur du
monde j'ai traqué le moindre indice en
lien avec
l'avatar c'est ma
[Musique]
destinée
je suis incapable de stopper la Nation
du Feu je ne veux pas de cette
responsabilité tu es pas
seul
moi l'immense boule de poil volante tout
le
nécessaire le monde a besoin de toi on
doit se rappeler ce qui motive notre
combat les
gens que l'on
aime je suis l'avatar et je veux pouvoir
sauver le
monde avec mes
amis ch caka czeka
[Musique]
CAK